president Trump gears up for his Supreme
Court pick Democrats panic and Jim
Jordan finds himself under the gun I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
oh I had such a nice relaxing weekend it
was my 10th anniversary with my wife and
she's made me a better person I know
that's almost impossible to believe that
I used to be a worse person than I am
now considering how terrible I am as a
human being now but it's true I used to
be even worse and then she made me a
better person so it was a really nice
weekend got suspended with my kids and
then we come back and today is the
glorious day president Trump about to
pick a successor to Justice Anthony
Kennedy on the Supreme Court we're gonna
get into all of that first I want to
remind you our next episode of the
conversation is almost here Tuesday July
17 5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific
all of your questions will be answered
by our own Andrew Clavin with our hosts
Alicia Kraus our live Q&A will be
available on YouTube and Facebook for
everyone to watch only daily wire
subscribers can ask drew questions in
real time if you want to submit your
questions you log into daily wire.com
you head over to the conversation page
and that's where you watch the live
stream and then you type your question
into the daily wear chat box and you can
have it read and answered on the air so
go check it out again subscribe ask drew
live questions Tuesday July 17 5:30 p.m.
Eastern 202 p.m. Pacific join the
conversation and get your questions
answered by a guy who looks like
Professor X but doesn't actually have
telekinetic abilities already so we also
want to remind you that you ought to
shop with stamps.com so here is the
reality these days you can get
essentially everything you could
possibly want on demand but you're still
heading down to the post office now you
may love the post office post office may
be a great place but you know it's more
convenient than heading down to the post
office it is being in your office and
just printing out the postage directly
on to a sticker or directly on to an
envelope or directly on to a piece of
paper and then taping it to an envelope
because then you don't have to get in
your car and then you'd have to go down
to the post office
well stamps comm allows you to do all
this stuff you can access all the
amazing services of the post office
right from your desk 24/7 when it is
convenient for you you buy and print
official US postage for any letter any
package using your own computer and
printer the mail carrier picks it right
up just click print mail you're done it
couldn't be any easier we use it here at
the Daily wire offices I use it at my
house as well and right now you can use
Shapiro for a special offer
this is the promo code okay it includes
up to 55 bucks of free postage a digital
scale and a four week trial
don't wait go to stamps calm and before
you do anything else click on the radio
microphone at the top of the home page
type in promo code Shapiro that stamps
comm promo codes appear for that special
deal 55 bucks free postage digital scale
four week trial and you never have to go
to the post office again
no matter how much love the post-office
easier to sit at your desk go to stamps
calm and use that promo code Shapiro at
the top of the homepage for that special
deal and to let them know that we sang
alrighty so today's the day guys
President Trump is gonna make his big
pick tonight 9:00 p.m. Eastern who gets
the Rose who gets to go to the honeymoon
suite with President Trump uh you have
to love how President Trump trots this
stuff out I do love this sort of
showmanship from President Trump I
enjoyed it when he did it with with
Justice Gorsuch I'm enjoying it even
more this time because the wails and
gnashing of teeth that can be heard in
the background are just glorious to
behold we'll get into some of those
wails and gnashing of teeth in just a
second president Trump tweeted out
looking forward to announcing my final
decision and the US Supreme Court
justice at 9:00 p.m. Eastern tomorrow
night at the White House an exceptional
person will be chosen and the best part
of this is obviously the bathing suit
competition that's that's the part I'm
looking forward to the most
although I have to say that I don't
think that the people he's considering
among our made chart high on that aspect
but here are basically he's down
according to every one to four picks
okay and I'm gonna go through sort of
the criticisms that the major flaws in
the four picks cuz we can assume that
virtually any of these people are going
to be better than Justice Anthony
Kennedy although one of them I have my
serious doubts about so there are four
people that he is down to at this point
one is the the sort of frontrunner the
longtime frontrunner which suggests that
he's not gonna win right because in
every reality TV show there's the guy
who you think is gonna win and there's
the guy who's actually going to win and
they edit in the back room to make it
look like the guy who is going to who
actually loses as the guy who's about to
win so that guy is DC Circuit Court of
Appeals judge Brett Kavanaugh he's the
guy who all along we've been saying he's
the one who's gonna win
he's the one who's being pushed hardest
by Leonard Leo over at the Federalist
Society he's one has been pushed hardest
by team Bush he's a longtime bush lawyer
he was he was involved in the DOJ during
the Ken Starr hearings in in 1999-2000
they very close with a lot of members of
the bush team he was very instrumental
in pushing Chief Justice Roberts to the
Supreme Court which i think is a demerit
for him and then there's Third Circuit
Court of Appeals judge Thomas Hartman
he's one who's friends with Trump sister
said Trump knows a little bit then their
7th Circuit Court of Appeals judge Amy
Coney Barrett and then their Sixth
Circuit Court of Appeals judge Raymond
Catholic so let's go through the crits
the criticisms of each one of these
people so that you know who's the best
and who's the worst now I will give you
my preliminary ranking of these people
if I had to pick from these
for I would pick Barrett first and then
Catholic and then Cavanaugh
and then finally Hardman I think Hardman
is by far the weakest I think the
Cavanaugh is the second weakest of a not
supremely weak I think that Catholic is
pretty good and I think Barrett should
be pretty stellar so what are their
major flaws one of the major critiques
of these four candidates so let's start
with Brett Kavanaugh who's the purported
frontrunner so Kavanaugh again has a
heavy base of support among Bush
staffers because he's been sort of he
was a Republican operative for a long
time before he became this this a very
brilliant judge on the DC Circuit Court
of Appeals
so his critics essentially make
essentially make three claims joined by
maybe a fourth so first they argue that
in a case called 7:00 sky he went out of
his way to avoid jurisdiction over
Obamacare so Obamacare was was sued the
federal government was sued over
Obamacare the case was that Obamacare
was unconstitutional and and Cavanaugh
looked at that case and what he said is
I don't have jurisdiction to decide this
case because this case is adjudicated
under something called the
anti-injunction Act the anti-injunction
Act holds that attacks cannot actually
be adjudicated by the DC Circuit Court
of Appeals so what he said is that
Obamacare was not a fine that when the
government threatened to find you've
hidden by Obamacare that was not a fine
does attacks he was the first person to
actually articulate that position and
that position ended up being used by
Chief Justice John Roberts and of course
his famously awful decision in which he
suggested that Obamacare was
constitutional that Congress could
create attacks but they couldn't create
a specific fine forcing you to buy
things so that is case number one so
Cavanaugh's defenders will say that this
is an example of Kavanagh using judicial
restraints now judicial restraint is a
term that's very often used by people
who don't know what they are talking
about when it comes to when it comes to
the law so there are a lot of folks who
will use two terms judicial activism and
judicial restraint and they will
contrast these two things a judicial
activist is a person who muddies the
waters by getting involved the judge who
gets involved in overrules lots of stuff
and somebody who exercises judicial
restraint is a judge who does his best
not to rule on cases because he believes
that most things ought to be left to the
legislature well that doesn't answer the
question of where the judge should be
involved in where the judge should not
be involved because of course if you
were to take these two terms to the
logical extreme than any attempt to
overrule any statute at all would amount
to judicial activism and any attempt to
allow the legislature to go forward on
any basis
would amount to judicial restraint
nobody actually believes in total
judicial activism or total judicial
restraint the question is what standard
do you use when you are overruling a
particular case so I don't like the
terms judicial activism and judicial
restraint I'm more interested in
judicial philosophy why would you
overrule a case why would you not
overrule why would you not overrule a
particular law that's the real question
here so when Cavanaugh's defenders say
well he was exercising judicial
restraint the question is well was he
right to do so in that case I do not
think that he was right to do so okay
second area of criticism about Brett
Kavanaugh critics argue that in a case
called priests for life Kavanagh
expressed that the government had a
compelling government interest in
providing contraceptive coverage so in
priests for life basically my
understanding is there was a religious
group that was not providing
contraceptive coverage to some employee
and Cavanaugh in his ruling he dissented
from the from the main ruling in his
dissent he acknowledged that the
government had a compelling government
interest in providing contraceptive
coverage now there's no reason to
acknowledge that because the government
does not in fact have a compelling
government interest in mandating
contraceptive coverage why exactly is it
in the government's interest to mandate
that my insurance program covers an IUD
and why what does the government have to
do with that why isn't that just about
me and my employer but Cavanaugh sort of
accepted that premise
Cavanaugh's fans say that he was just
reflecting the Supreme Court holding in
Hobby Lobby I think that's pretty
dubious okay third critics say that in a
case called Garza Cavanaugh didn't join
in dissent that criticized roe v wade
this is a case where an illegal
immigrant seventeen year old came to the
United States you want an abortion and
she was not given one by the government
the government said well you haven't
been released you've been remanded into
the custody to custody of a relative yet
and we do not have the obligation to
make sure you get over to an abortion
provider to make sure you get that
abortion so Cavanaugh didn't vote that
the woman should be able to get an
abortion but in that case he did not
actually criticize roe v wade instead
what he said is that the government
might have some sort of interest in in
granting her an abortion under roe v
wade but that her status as an illegal
immigrant trumped all of that well the
problem with that of course is that roe
v wade is a badly decided case and there
was another dissent that criticized roe
v wade
he finally Cavanaugh granted standing to
an atheist suing the government over the
Pledge of Allegiance
that's always sort of a weird thing so
there's something in law called standing
standing means that you can't sue unless
you have actually been damaged by
something so if I am
damaged by you right let's say that
let's say that just hits me with her car
I know it's standing to sue her because
now I have been damaged by Jess's car
however if just it's Mathis with her car
I can't sue Jess first of all why would
i but second of all if just hits Mathis
with her car I'm not involved in that
case I don't have standing to sue ok
well the same thing holds true with
regard to federal litigation so you
don't have standing to sue just because
a law affects you right the law has to
specifically target you as to affect you
in a way that violates the law well
there's a case in which an atheist sued
the government over the Pledge of
Allegiance yeah there's there's no stand
there's no actual damages shown by the
person who heard of the Pledge of
Allegiance but was not forced to
Stanford if you're forced to stand or
put your hand over your heart for the
Pledge of Allegiance then you'd have
standing in this case the Atheist did
not have standing but Kavanagh granted
standing anyway so that's another
criticism of Kavanagh so those are the
criticisms of Kavanagh
ok now Thomas Hartman so there are a lot
more criticisms of Hardman so Hardman
was the runner-up to now justice Gorsuch
just last year as I recall I was
actually very critical of Hardman I
thought the gore search would be a much
better pick and thank God president made
the right call on that there are a bunch
of areas in which he is too soft first
there was a case called prowl in which
Hardiman found that a homosexual
quote-unquote effeminate man that was
the description in the case could be
discriminated against under under title
seven of the Civil Rights Act based on
gender stereotyping despite the fact
that this does not reflect the text of
title 7 so under title seven
I can't discriminate against just
because she is a woman and I can't do
that but if just were a lesbian then I
cook and I don't know but yeah I assume
nachos which is boyfriend in any case
yet right just I don't want on it like
not there's anything wrong with that
folks but just it just as straight okay
in any case if under title seven of the
Civil Rights Act okay okay I can
actually under title seven discriminate
against homosexuals now there are state
laws that prevent in many cases
discriminating against homosexuals but
title seven doesn't cover sexual
orientation it only says I can't
discriminate against Jess because she's
a woman and I can't discriminate against
Mathis because he's a man I can
discriminate however on the basis of
sexual orientation
well in this case a gay man sued his
employer saying he was being
discriminated against not because he was
gay but because he was an effeminate man
okay and judge Hardiman found that he
expanded title seven of the Civil Rights
Act to cover appearance as an effeminate
man in gender stereo
which is a pretty radical redefinition
of title seven of the Civil Rights Act
so there's that second in n-double a-c-p
fourth versus North Hudson Regional Fire
and Rescue judge Hardiman rule to strike
down a fire departments residency
requirement based on a finding of
disparate impact so this has always been
a weird aspect of the Civil Rights Act
is the disparate impact test
virtually every law has a disparate
impact any law that you pass has a
disparate impact if I pass a law against
thievery against stealing then then
people who are people who are
kleptomaniacs are disproportionately
impacted there's a disparate impact i'm
kleptomaniacs if for example I were to
pass a law that said that you're not
allowed to buy certain types you're not
allowed to buy Manischewitz wine for
whatever reason you decide that
Manischewitz wine is damaging to the
psyche because it tastes like cough
syrup and therefore you ban on the sale
of Manischewitz wine okay first of all
unclear that's constitutional but let's
say that it's a perfectly legal law it
would have a disparate impact because
most of the people who are drinking
Manischewitz are old Jews right so that
is so that would have a disparate impact
does that mean that the law is per se
illegal not really you have to show that
there was intent behind the law you have
to show that the law was designed to
have disparate impact not that the law
just had disparate impact well in this
case there was a residency requirement
for the fire department and Hartman said
well just because there's a residency
requirement that means that not enough
black people are getting in and that
means that there's disparate impact that
means the law is discriminatory that's a
little bit dicey okay I'm gonna get to
the other claims against Hardiman in
just a second first I want to say thanks
to our sponsors over at clip so here is
the reality you are not brushing your
teeth properly I know you lied your
dentist they always ask you so how long
do you brush your teeth and you don't
know and then you say I brush my teeth
for 30 minutes a night that is a lie and
you know that you are lying when you say
that instead what you really need to cuz
you're have a stopwatch I mean let's
face this you go to the bathroom and
brush your teeth you kind of swish the
brush around you're done okay that's not
how it ought to work instead you all
have equipped toothbrush it's the new
electric toothbrush that packs just the
right amount of vibration into a slimmer
design and a fraction of the cost of
bulkier traditional electric brushes
guiding pulses alert you want to switch
sides make them brushing the right
amount effortless equip also comes with
a mount that sections right to your
mirror it sticks to use as a cover for a
hygienic travel anywhere and qyp has a
subscription plan so the brush heads
arrive on a dentist recommended schedule
every three months for just five bucks
including free shipping worldwide
qyp is backed by a network of over
10,000 dental professionals
just fantastic um it's really it's user
friendly and it starts just 25 bucks if
you go to get quick comm slash Shapiro
right now you get your first refill pack
for free with a quip electric toothbrush
that's first refill pack free get quip
comm slash up here oh that's GE t qu IP
comm slash up here I'll use that slash
appear oh so that they know that we sent
you it really is a fantastic product
check it out get quick comm slash
Shapiro right now you get that first
refill pack free and it starts at just
25 bucks with that quip electric
toothbrush okay so back to you Thomas
Hardeman who is again one of the
possibilities for president Trump we've
already talked about a couple of the
claims against him third in a case
called Val de Diez o goldenbez Hardiman
ruled that an illegal immigrant could
claim asylum based on targeting by ms-13
in his home country now asylum usually
means that the government has to be
targeting you or that the government is
going out of its way not to protect you
from criminals so let's say you're
targeted by ms-13 you go to the
government you say I'm being targeted by
ms-13 and the government laughs in your
face and says I hope ms-13 gets you
right then you might be able to claim
asylum in the United States but just
because you're targeted by a criminal
somewhere else on the planet does not
mean you get asylum in the United States
Hardiman however ruled then the illegal
immigrant could claim asylum
thanks to that targeting fourth Hardiman
is not exactly a critic of so called
Chevron deference Chevron deference is
there's a very famous case called
Chevron in which the Supreme Court held
that when an administrative agency
decides that basically let's say that
you have a fight with the EPA it's an
administrative agency the Environmental
Protection Agency and they've ruled that
a pond on your koi pond on your property
is actually a protected federal wetland
and therefore you cannot actually have
those koi in there they're going to
clean out the koi okay if let so you go
to the EPA and you say that's not right
and they send you to an administrative
court and then the court rules in favor
of the EPA so you sue and you send it to
the judiciary well normally the
judiciary would be able to look at that
case de novo meaning they'd actually be
able to look at that case and say well
is that's right or is this wrong but
according to Chevron administrative
agencies deserve deference - you ought
to allow the EPA to decide its own fate
hey Chevron deference is really stupid
but Hardiman has has not been a critic
of Chevron deference as he instead he's
basically stood up for it
v critics have charged that Hardman is
not textual in this a textualist enough
that he hasn't focused enough on the
words of the Constitution or the law and
said he focuses on legislative history
and finally hardiman's critics point to
the fact that he's very close
Trump's liberal sister who sits on the
circuit court and his wife is a
prominent Democrat okay so Hardiman is
by far the weakest of these candidates
okay the other two are Barrett and
Catholic so Amy Kony Barrett who again
sits on the sixth so the Seventh Circuit
Court of Appeals rather she doesn't
there's not a lot to criticize her about
because her record isn't very long she
only joined the Seventh Circuit Court of
Appeals last year hasn't been there for
very long otherwise she's very
originalist from her writing she's very
textualist she obviously doesn't like
roe v wade very much she obviously is
not a fan of government intervention ISM
so she's my first pick and there's judge
Raymond Catholic they're a bunch of
people on the right who's been
criticizing Catholic saying that
Catholic is not anti-illegal immigration
enough I think these it's basically
groundless I think that groups like
Breitbart that have been targeting
Catholics on behalf of Cavanaugh I think
they're fibbing I think that they are
manipulating the actual case law so for
example there's a case like Van Daan ago
when in which Catholic ruled that a
particular legal immigrant was not
actually was not actually violative of
the he was not a felon even though he
had committed Grand Theft Auto that's
not because Catholics wanted the illegal
limit in the country that's cuz the
statute didn't define Grand Theft Auto
as in as a violent felony under the
statute so Catholic is just a good judge
so in order of my ranking Barratt
Catholic Kavanagh Hardeman we'll have to
see what happens tonight okay meanwhile
folks on the Left are losing it because
they think this is the end of the world
and they've demonstrated full scale how
radical they are when it comes to the
Supreme Court they believe the Supreme
Court exists merely to uphold their
policy priorities I believe the Supreme
Court exists mainly to uphold the
Constitution the left will never discuss
the Constitution the left will
immediately discuss Roe if you ask
anybody on the Left what do you want out
of the Supreme Court justice that person
on the Left will never say I want them
to uphold the words of the Constitution
never they will never say that instead
what they will say is I want that
justice to uphold roe v wade roe v wade
is not in the Constitution roe v wade is
not law it will view it as judicial
decision that judicial decision is wrong
and it's stupid and it's badly argued
and it's badly written it's wrong on
virtually every score but this just
demonstrates what the left thinks the
judiciary is there to do which has
imposed their policy preferences from
above so the near all president the
National Abortion Rights Action League
they changed their name because they
didn't like to have the name abortion in
there so they just call themselves nay
wrong
though it has no meaning the narrow
aisle president at least Hogue she was
on Fox News Sunday and she says that
from any judge who is who is asked to be
on the Supreme Court we want an
affirmative declaration that roe v wade
is going to be upheld
we need an affirmative declaration right
we need and I think even Susan Collins
said this when she said she needs to see
a nominee demonstrate their commitment
to upholding roe versus wade and keeping
abortion but even what the hell does
that have to do the Constitution the
answer is nothing the left doesn't care
about the Constitution however the left
believes that the Constitution is merely
an impediment to their policy goals and
it is amazing me the people on the right
will say we don't need a litmus test for
judges we shouldn't have a litmus test
for judges no I think we should have a
litmus test I think the litmus test on
the right should be will you vote to
overturn roe v wade like if we were
actually honest about this stuff we just
ask just judges this stuff and judges
would answer honestly but we can't do
that anymore ever since justice Bork so
instead we have stealth candidates where
we asked them about roe v wade and they
say well i'd have to see the facts of
the case in front of me
roe v wade obviously is binding
precedent right they're all gonna say
the same thing because precedent is a
fudge word and when people say they're
going to abide by precedent what they
really mean is I'm going to abide by the
cases that are on the books until I
don't want them to be on the books
anymore so one point Bowers V Hardwick
which said that states could ban sodomy
right that was on the books and then
that was overturned right that was
overturned by the Supreme Court in
Lawrence vs Texas at one point Plessy
vs. Ferguson which which said
segregation was legal that was
overturned that was on the books for 58
years in the United States before it was
overturned so you know when people
suggest that precedent is the be-all
end-all what they really mean is cases I
like I want upheld in cases I don't like
I want to overturn constitutional
interpretation at least on hot-button
issues like abortion is actually not all
that difficult people deliberately
obscure the questions so they can get to
their preferred policy recommendations
now the left has moved extraordinarily
radical on abortion they now see
abortion not just as something they want
protected but as the sacrament itself
and they're they're proving how foolish
they are every single day so there is a
in a bizarre demonstration yesterday
we're so concerned with owning the cons
and owning Libs these days that people
are willing to do the stupidest possible
things so a bunch of women decided to go
out and dress themselves in handmaids
tails outfits because that they went
they got like red habits they got like
red
robes in the and the white potato chip a
potato chip hats and all the rest of us
and they and they're wandering around
Arizona in the 110 degree weather in
order to own the Khans or something say
here they were walking around and
jabbering about roe v wade you can see
them here saying it says keep your
theology off our biology get out of our
privates ladies I have no interest
okay the keep your theology and then
there's pictures of abortion hangers and
all these women who are walking around
in 110 degree weather as though they are
going to be made handmaidens if they
can't kill the babies inside their womb
the most obvious example by the way of
the stupidity of the left on this issue
comes courtesy of Michelle wolf who is
just an awful human being so Michelle
wolf you'll recall from being terrible
at comedy and also being on the White
House Correspondents Dinner where she
yelled about her vagina or somesuch she
decided that in honor of the 4th of July
the most American thing she could think
of was killing your baby in the woman
cutting its brain out so here she is
doing her fourth of July special in
which she does a full-on star-spangled
tribute to killing your baby in the womb
[Music]
[Applause]
god bless abortions and god bless
america
and says the breaks 10th annual salute
to abortion Wow god Bless America and
God bless abortion the perverse level of
love for abortion abortion as a
sacrament abortion is a sign of bravery
abortion is a sign of decency on the
left this is why they are so concerned
that roe v wade is gonna be able to turn
not because roe v wade being overturned
will actually amount to the legalization
of abortion but simply because they're
afraid that people might actually want
to vote on the issue of whether you
ought to kill your baby in the womb and
they can't win this argument because
this argument is unwinnable people
should not be allowed to kill babies in
the womb even most Democrats believe
that there should be significant
restrictions on the ability to kill a
baby in the womb and they may not agree
on how early you banned that but most of
them agree that 20 weeks and on that
should be banned okay so Michelle wolf
is like did this radicalism is really
insane it shows why they're so concerned
with the with the NAM and with the
nomination of this judge of this justice
because they believe the Supreme Court
is all that stands between them
getting rid of something that they hold
holy namely the ability to kill your
child in the womb okay so I want to talk
about the conservative sort of response
to some of the Supreme Court's on
particularly roe v wade in just a second
first let's talk about whether you shave
or shower or brush your teeth or do all
the things that make you into a
presentable human being in the morning
if you do you need to talk to my friends
over at Dollar Shave Club because Dollar
Shave Club has pretty much everything
you need to get ready in the bathroom
any particular product that is
particularly great then that comes to
mind they've got it okay so they're my
favorite and the best one is they have
this calming body cleanser it is so
great okay because as you can tell I'm
not a calm guy by nature but the calming
body cleanser smells delightful okay
this is amber and lavender it smells so
good and it makes you feel so clean you
name it they've got the shampoo the
conditioner the body wash the toothpaste
the hair gel they even have a wipe that
will leave your butt feeling tingly
clean all of Dollar Shave club's
products are made with top-shelf
ingredients they will not break your
budget you will feel the difference plus
shipping is included with your
membership and there's a great way to
try a bunch of Dollar Shave Club
products for just five bucks you can get
their daily essentials starter set it
comes with body cleanser one wipe
Charlies which are the amazing butt
wipes the world-famous shave butter and
their best razor that six blade
executive keep the blades coming for a
few bucks more month add in shampoo
toothpaste anything else you need for
the bathroom check it all out at
dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash menus that
slash Benson for the special deal and to
let them know we sent you it's really
the products are just first-rate go
check it out dollarshaveclub.com slash
pen there's a reason everybody's
switching to Dollar Shave Club okay so
with the left so militants about
abortion that they are talking about
abortion is a sacrament I'm old enough
to remember when Bill Clinton said
abortion should be safe legal and rare
I'm old enough to remember that now it's
abortion should be plentiful available
and celebrated we should cheer for it
because killing a baby in the womb is a
sign of womanhood it's a sign that you
are truly a woman in charge of your own
life if you have not actually killed the
baby in her womb that means that you are
subjecting yourself to the hierarchical
preferences of evil masculinity if you
kill a baby in the womb that shows that
you've stood up to the man sure you
might kill the baby in the process but
at least just stood up to the man this
is the perspective of someone left now
the pro-life issue is one on which the
right can win and should win because
this is an issue that is as vital
morally as any issue the United States
has ever faced
up to an including slavery in the murder
of a million babies
in the womb is a serious moral issue and
if you don't think it's a serious moral
issue it's because you haven't looked at
it hard enough okay but folks on the
right tend to shy away from this and
it's a serious problem so Leonard Leo
who's one of the fellows who's helping
Trump select the the next Supreme Court
justice he was on Sunday with he's on
this week on ABC and he said that rumors
of Roe being overturned that's greatly
exaggerated why is it always the job of
the right to quality quell rumors about
Roe being overturned I don't understand
this
why shouldn't the right say hell yes we
want to overturn Roe because it's a bad
decision why shouldn't that be something
the right campaigns on the by the way
overturning Roe does not mean that
abortion becomes illegal across 50
states if you think that that California
is suddenly going to ban abortion you're
out of your mind California's not gonna
ban abortion me there's Massachusetts
neither is New York me there's New
Jersey neither is Illinois right there
are too many states in the Union that
are going to allow abortion to continue
unfettered but the right is constantly
running away from their own positions on
this stuff so Leonard Leo whom I think
is is a quite brilliant legal mind
here's saying what Rose not gonna be
overturned like let's stop with all the
fright what why is everyone so worried
first of all nobody really knows we've
been talking about this for 36 years
going all the way back to the nomination
of sandra o'connor and after that 36
year period we only have a single
individual on the court who is expressly
said he would overturn Roe so I think
it's a bit of a scare tactic and rank
speculation more than anything else okay
so you know all of the talk about don't
worry about it it's just speculation the
right is constantly attempting to run
away from this issue so more evidence of
this Tommy Lehren you know who you know
I've refrained from criticizing
generally because you know Tommy knows
what Tommy does but Tommy Lehren has has
now made the case that we should never
speak about abortion this is of course
because she is pro-choice Tommy Lehren
is pro-abortion she went on the view and
she suggested that it's only religious
objection to abortion that was driving
the rights objection to abortion so she
was on Fox News final thoughts and she
suggested that Republicans only win by
staying out of the social issues to be
honest the federal government does few
things well and I believe regulating
social issues is an area where it fails
let the churches the nonprofits and the
community groups step in not Almighty
Uncle Sam okay so I am generally
friendly to libertarian arguments but
this is not
any social issue when you are talking
about abortion when you are talking
about abortion you're talking about an
issue of protecting human life okay by
this definition slavery is a social
issue by the way Tommy Lehren is very
fond of talking about social issues when
it suits her purposes I mean how many
times you've heard Tommy learn and talk
about the flag and patriotism and
kneeling for the national anthem and
culture I mean that's what Tommy learn
specializes in she's not exactly a
Milton Friedman economist right you're
not gonna hear her sitting there
spouting Vienna School of Economics
explanations of trade theory right
that's that's not Tommy's thing so for
her to say that we are not going to
focus in on social issues because we
don't because otherwise we're never
going to win I think is is foolish not
only is it foolish let's be real about
this if the right is not fighting to
protect human life then the right is not
doing its job no victory that leaves
behind babies and the woman to be carved
apart and then flushed down a toilet no
right that does that in the name of
victory is winning a victory that is
worth that is worth fighting for victory
has to mean something
and one of those things that victory has
to mean is standing up for the lives of
the unborn now Tommy responded to to all
of this she got heavy flak from a lot of
folks on the right for saying all of
this that the right should leave behind
the social issues by the way Donald
Trump didn't leave behind the social
issues during the election cycle he's
very pro-life during the election cycle
at least insofar as what he had to say
when Tommy then tweeted something out
about how she's not going to be coddled
into believing something that she
doesn't believe no one's trying to
control Tommy into into believing
something shows but she's certainly able
to believe whatever she wants to believe
the point I'm making is that she's wrong
so she tweeted out so I formed my
political beliefs based on acceptance
from the self-appointed thought wardens
of either political party no and I never
will you don't have to like or agree
with my thoughts but at least you know
they are my own a couple of things about
this this seems to be the last refuge of
people who can't make a good argument
nowadays that you make an argument and
then they say you're not gonna box me in
with your standards and I'm trying to
box you and make your argument I just
think your argument sucks like that's
not me boxing you in I've heard the same
from several relatively major figures in
the in the past several weeks that if I
say that I don't like something that
you've said that suddenly I'm trying to
I'm trying to provoke you into moving
your position no I'm trying to present a
different position you can say whatever
you want it's a free country you can
make a bad argument if you want to also
the substitution of authenticity for
solid thinking is is not even an hour
it's an emotional appeal this idea that
you don't have to like or agree with my
thoughts but at least you know they are
my own right I assume they are your own
which is why I am criticizing you or if
there's somebody else's I'd be
criticizing them then the substitution
of authenticity well he's very authentic
in how he feels therefore you really
shouldn't question therefore you really
shouldn't question what what they have
to say that doesn't make any sense to me
at all I just I think that's completely
nonsensical on virtually every level
okay meanwhile I don't want to you know
Center on my criticism for folks on the
right because the reality is that folks
on the left continue to to be more and
more extreme in every possible way over
the weekend there there is more it's
more sort of extreme behavior from folks
and left the point is I don't think that
we ought to surrender our principles
simply because the left is really
militant on issues like abortion I think
that ought to make us more militant at
least in our in our pursuit of the right
principles I don't mean more militant
like physically but I do mean then we
ought to stand up strongly and proudly
for the positions in which we believe
particularly when they happen to be
purely moral as in protection of human
life they wouldn't talk about the
extremism of left in just a second
because there are more incidents of
Trump administration officials being
targeted by folks on the left over the
weekend first however you're gonna have
to go over to Daily wire calm and check
it out so when you go over to Daily wire
then you get the rest of the show live
you get the rest of the Michael Knoll
show live the rest of the Andrew Klavan
show live you get to be part of our
mailbag on Friday that means you get to
ask your questions and get your answers
when there's an episode of the
conversation as there will be July 17th
with Andrew Klavan next week then you
get to ask questions if you are a
subscriber plus when you go to daily
wired.com slash events and you decide
that you wanna buy tickets to our Dallas
or Phoenix events coming up in August
when you do all of that then one of the
things that you get is the ability by
VIP tickets before anybody else when you
are a member so lots of great things
Plus with the annual subscription you
get this the leftist year's hot or cold
tumbler it refreshes you it makes you
feel renewed it makes you feel like a
new human being that's what this does
right here this leftist cheers hot or
cold tumbler you get that for 99 bucks a
year which is cheaper than the monthly
subscription also make sure you go over
to youtube or itunes to subscribe we had
our latest Sunday special they came out
yesterday there was a stand with with
Sam Harris and that was really great
this week I believe that we are going to
be doing our Sunday special with Dennis
Prager it is my understanding so that
should be a blast so you definitely want
to go and subscribe over YouTube or
iTunes to make sure it shows up in your
inbox go check it out we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
all righty so meanwhile it seems like
virtually every member of the Trump
administration is now being confronted
in public like this is this sort of
thing is happening all the time and it
ranges from current members of the Trump
administration to past members of the
Trump administration so the so the
latest such incident happened over the
weekend so apparently Stephen Miller
who's sort of the president's
immigration guru former Jeff Sessions
acolyte he apparently ordered eighty
bucks of takeout sushi thus according to
Washington Post from a restaurant near
his apartment a bartender followed him
into the street and shouted Stephen when
Miller turned around the bartender
raised both middle fingers and cursed at
him according to an account Miller has
shared with White House colleagues
outraged Miller threw the sushi away he
later told colleagues I'm not sure why
you would throw away the sushi the
sushis probably still pretty good seems
like a waste of perfectly good sushi
give it to a homeless person or
something if you're not gonna eat it but
in any case this just demonstrates the
vile behavior the to many on the right
are experiencing Mitch McConnell was was
confronted on the street over the
weekend and people were telling him that
they knew where he lived
- which cocaine Mitch responded I work
hard for this and then he snorted a line
and took out his machine gun so cocaine
mitch is not gonna be having any of that
he just unleashed Elaine Chao and Elaine
Chao came out just like claws claws
Unleashed like Wolverine so you want to
go to McConnell House get ready gang
yeah ready gang I mean that that dude
has been what have you ever seen narcos
okay this is why you don't go up to a
cocaine dealer and say you know where he
lives so here's what it looked like over
the weekend when someone went up to to
the cocaine Mitch
[Music]
[Applause]
oh sorry okay so the screaming at people
that you know where they live is always
a really delightful mode of political
expression as someone who's received a
number of death threats and who has a
shotgun for precisely this purpose I
promise you the Mitch McConnell is not
all that worried about people knowing
where he lives again but the extremism
of folks on the left you feel the need
to do this is pretty astonishing the
same thing happened to Steve Bannon now
as you know Steve Bannon former White
House chief strategist sloppy Steve as
the president so memorably named him I
am NOT a fan of sloppy Steve I have been
a not fan of sloppy Steve for many years
in fact I was one of the first not fans
of sloppy Steve in the pages of the
Washington Post I talked about the
shortcomings of sloppy Steve as a human
being when I quit Breitbart news I
talked about how sloppy Steve was not a
great person to say the least
okay but sloppy Steve still has a right
to go to a bookstore hey Steve Bannon
sells rights go to a bookstore dudes an
inveterate reader and he likes going to
bookstores so he went to a bookstore
apparently in in Richmond Virginia and
the bookstore was called the blacks it's
called Black Swan books and some idiot
person this this woman came up to him in
the aisles and started yelling at him in
the bookstore which is just a delightful
thing to do right listen again I just
like Steve Bannon which is why I avoid
him I have a lot more cause to dislike
Steve ban and then some some random
woman at a bookstore she starts yelling
at Steve Bannon in the bookstore because
she's a jerk and the owner of the
bookstore whose name is Nick cook he
promptly asks her to leave and she said
no and he said well if you don't leave
I'm gonna call the cops on you at which
point she left she said this was the end
of the story however it was not the end
of the story because it turns out the
left is awful so a bunch of folks on the
Left including a former Hillary staffer
decided it was time to docks the
bookstore owner it was time to go after
the bookstore owner for having the
temerity to say customers in my store
ought not be abused on my premises like
for forget whether or not you like Steve
Bannon forget whether or not Steve
Bannon is in there buying books you
don't like then then that matters if you
are a store owner if I own a restaurant
and randos keep invading my restaurant
and yelling at the customers I am going
to call the cops because I run a
restaurant but this according to the
left is not acceptable in any way so you
have this guy Raphael Schumann ah've who
is a techie political artist who
apparently started going through the the
history of the bookstore owner and go
after the guy's wife because his wife
was I guess a National Episcopal
treasurer and then there's a
correspondent for Ross story who said
that Nick cook won't tolerate anyone
calling out white supremacy even after
the fatal outright March in
Charlottesville he wants everyone to
know his sources store is a safe place
for fascism or maybe his store is just a
safe place for his customers and then
there's a TV writer who suggested that
this bookstore thinks Steve Danon should
be allowed to shop peacefully well it's
gonna be pretty peaceful there when
everyone stops shopping at this
bookstore so now unless you allow people
to harass people on your premises we are
going to destroy your business just
delightful the best was Phillip Raines
who's just a garbage human being so
Phillip Raines is a former Hillary
Clinton advisor and staffer very
longtime staffer was with her at the
State Department and goes back with her
probably 20 years well he tweeted out
the store's address phone number and
email address and then he told the Daily
Caller
you have some very fine people on both
sides which is of course a reference to
Charlottesville they may want to contact
the store as many did after Sarah
slanders trade mark was asked by the
owner to leave the redhead restaurant so
clever for convenience I copied and
pasted the store's Contact Us page
presumably they post their contact
information on the world wide web in the
hopes people contact them hence the name
contact us that's all it's not like I
tweeted Lindsey Graham cell phone number
then he added I'm providing a service to
the public by providing the contact
information the bookstore posted on
their website presumably with the hope
of being contacted this sort of
delightful behavior is certainly likely
to drive more people into Donald Trump's
camp there is just no question there's
no question and it should drive people
into Donald Trump's camp because the
extremism of the left is making it
unpalatable for people in the center to
vote for them and it's not just these
these fringe political actors who are
now being egged on by the likes of
Maxine Waters their mainstream political
Democrats who are saying things that are
fully insane so dick Durbin who is a
senator from Illinois he just said that
detained children in the United States
right these detained migrant kids are
coming across the border with their
illegal immigrant parents and now are
being detained because we can't just
release them in to the public right we
have to either separate them from their
parents and give them to a relative or
they have to stay with their parents
those are the only two choices well now
dick Durbin is comparing those kids who
by law have to be separated by that from
from their parents or could be kept with
their parents in detention because their
parents are illegal immigrants now dick
Durbin is comparing those kids to these
Thai kids who are stuck in a cave
literally you know we've been following
this story they're all these Thai kids
from like a soccer team I guess who are
stuck in a cave in Thailand they've been
had a bit they've had to be brought out
one by one cuz they came flooded so he's
now comparing detained immigrants
detained illegal immigrant children to
Thai kids who may drown yeah it's
exactly this hittin by the way dick
durbin is the same idiot who compared
American troops to Pol Pot and Stalin so
and not not a great shock for the
senator from Illinois who has narrate to
nutria Neary to neural connections to
rub together so here he is hearts and
prayers are with those boys in Thailand
trapped in the cave
I hope our hearts and prayers are also
with thousands of children toddlers and
infants removed from their parents by
the Trump administration under zero
tolerance they're trapped in a
bureaucratic cave - yeah it's just the
same and they're trapped in a
bureaucratic cave you know like with the
judiciary and with actual due process of
law it's exactly like almost being
drowned in a cave exactly the same thing
yeah I can't imagine why folks are
looking at dick Durbin and saying yeah
this is this is all a little bit not
demand is all a little bit too much of
me now in a second I want to discuss all
the scandal that's now broken out around
Jim Jordan so Jim Jordan is a guy who
wants to run for Speaker of the House
full disclosure I'm friendly with
representative Jordan I've met him a
couple of times he asked me to speak on
a panel in Washington DC we've talked on
the phone a couple of times it's pretty
much the extent of it but representative
Jordan is now being accused of covering
up the team doctor at Ohio State
University who was apparently basically
fondling examining the men so as a team
doctor was sexually harassing the men on
the wrestling team and Jim Jordan was
then a 21 year old coach is like first
year out of college and he was I guess
training for the Olympic wrestling team
and the accusation is that he knew that
this team doctor was basically harassing
the men and he did nothing about it and
that he is therefore a sort of Penn
State type so here's Jim Jordans
response to exactly those reports I mean
I never saw never heard of never was
told about any type of abuse if I had
been I would have dealt with it our
coaching staff we would have dealt with
these were our student-athletes if there
were people who were abused they deserve
justice but what has been said about me
is is completely false so what's
happening with
of these these former they're a bunch of
former students and they say that that
he had to have known right it's not that
they know that he knew is that he had to
have known so there's a guy named David
Range who wrestled in at OSU in the
1980s he spoke to The Washington Post
here's what he said
Jordan definitely knew these things were
happening yes most definitely it was
there he knew about it because it was an
everyday occurrence he said he never
discussed the issue directly with Jordan
one-on-one and did not know whether
anyone made a formal report but he said
Jordan was present during group
conversations in the locker room about
Strauss's behavior we talked about it
all the time in the locker room well
Jordan was there he said everybody joked
about it and talked about it all the
time and Jordan said well conversations
in a locker room are a lot different
than people coming up and talking about
abuse and people are getting on his case
for all of this now I have talked with
somebody who was at OSU while this was
happening who was actually a member of
the wrestling team during this period
and what he told me is that everybody
who is at on the OSU wrestling team knew
that the doctor was weird but they also
figured that the doctor was the doctor
that the university had had put him in
place because they wanted him there to
preside over thousands presumably of
young people to do checks he said that
this doctor was apparently the sort of
person who you'd come in with a cough
and they'd immediately want to check you
for a hernia you know right this is a
doctor who who is very not not covert
about the sort of pursuit of young men
particularly but but he also said is
that everybody sort of joked about this
guy was weirdo and remember these are
adults right these are young male adults
and I don't want pretend that males and
females are exactly the same okay
because I don't think they're exactly
that someone comes to matters like this
the chances that a male who is severely
sexually abused at age 19 by a by a
coach and by team doctor wouldn't go to
one of the coaches and say something or
punch the doctor when this happened
these guys on the wrestling team because
about as macho as it gets
you know the the fact that they're
joking around in the locker room and
Jordan was there while they're joking
around in the locker room I don't think
is exactly the same thing as somebody
filing a formal reports at Penn State
there were actual formal reports filed
in the accusation was that members of
the Penn State administration basically
ignored these formal reports knowing
what was going on also the accusation is
that this is happening to seven-year-old
kids not to 20 year old men but if this
was just a bunch of guys in the locker
room joking around my odd doctor
so-and-so what a weirdo he is
you remember that doctor that guy was
Richard Strauss remember that guy that
guy's a weirdo he just called me in
there and just started feeling me up
that was weird number he's laughing
about it not exactly
same thing as Jim Jordan was told that
this doctor was abusing people and then
he failed to report it up the chain it's
weird that Jordan is being targeted
considering there are literally hundreds
of members of the OSU athletic staff
right there's what are their accusations
that the upper level members of the oh
that like Jordans the only name you're
hearing here who are the other members
of the OSU staff who are being accused
of covering this up if there was an
active cover-up there's a lawsuit
ongoing presumably we'll get all the
information but people who are
suggesting that locker room joking is
exactly the same thing as filing a
formal report has never met either a
teenage guy or is or is being
disingenuous I think so and even the
reports from the Washington Post is
people saying well Jordan had to have
known this was happening first of all
had to have known as vague what this is
is vague right because I assume that
Jordan wasn't an expert in medical
procedure so maybe he just figured okay
the doctors a little weird but he's
doing his job
wait again if you're in position of
responsibility and someone went reported
to him that he'd been sexually abused by
the team doctrine he did nothing that is
a real problem if it was a bunch of guys
sitting around the locker room going god
that richard strauss guy what a weirdo
he is that guy he's always finding some
excuse to touch him in that weird and
everybody run allowed him yeah me too
man I was it was pretty weird and Jordan
going yeah me too because he was
presumably examined by the same team
doctor I'm having a hard time getting to
he was covering for abuse that he wanted
Richard Strauss to get away with the
abuse whose defender of the
administration that seems like a little
bit too much of a stretch for me to go
there now maybe new evidence arises but
from what I'm hearing I can't go all the
way to this is this is Penn State and
the and the upper level administration
of Penn State I just don't see the
evidence for that yet again maybe
that'll change okay time for some stuff
I like and then some stuff that I hate
will do a Federalist paper so stuff that
I like today so over the weekend I read
an excellent sci-fi book it's called
Summerlin by I'm gonna get the
pronunciation wrong here by its hanout
Rajan eme and the book is really
interesting and and really creative so
basically the premise of the book is it
takes place in 1938 and it's an
alternate history in which basically
mysticism is real but psychics are real
mediums are real there is in fact a
spirit world
and somehow people on earth have found a
way to get in touch with the spirit
world so when people die you can just
talk to them on the other side and the
people on the other side live in a place
called Summerland hence the title of the
book and Summerland is basically a lot
like
earth except you don't have a body your
disembodied and so there are all these
spy counselor spy missions that are
going on on both sides of the death
barrier that basically on the other side
they're still Soviets and on the other
side they're still British spies and
they're interacting with one another and
if you die in one place does mean you
die in the other so it's really
interesting and well done really clever
and a cool concept
check it out summer line by Hannah Roger
Naomi I'm a big fan of good sci-fi and
this is one of the other sci-fi books
that I've read in a long time actually I
think it's really really good so go
check that out ok other things that I
like so Chris Broussard and the sports
commentators now at Fox Sports one and
he it was basically thrown off of ESPN
as I recall because he made the comment
that religious people might not be in
favor of same-sex marriage and this is
not allowed to ESPN you're not allowed
to say the city SPN you have to be like
Jimmy Carter and say Jesus was totally
into same-sex marriage if you say that
the old and new testaments are not
particularly pro homosexual activity
then you get thrown off of ESPN well now
chris broussard is over at Fox Sports 1
and he was asked about being woke and he
made this comment which is just
spectacular you want to be a
revolutionary you want to be what the
most revolutionary thing a black man can
do in 2018 in America is partnered with
a wife and raised strong intelligent
black kids that are committed to the
upliftment of black people and have an
appreciation for their race but this is
exactly right ok what he said right
there is exactly right
being woke is not tied to how much you
hate the system being woke is make all
the right decisions in your life raise
your kids right so that they live better
lives than you do and also fight the
elements of the system that you think
are wrong you know the fact this is even
mildly controversial is astonishing but
Bruce art is exactly right there's
nothing you can do that is better for
the world and raising your children
correctly and it's the best thing you
can do for the world put everything else
aside raise your kids right you're
making the world a better place raise
them wrong you're making the world a
worse place it is the number one
contribution anyone on this planet makes
what you do with your kids ok time for
another so the other thing that I like
and this is pretty spectacular so build
a socialist Bill DeBlasio
spent the weekend at socialist Bernie
Sanders very socialist summer home
that's really great
I love how socialism is now this so
Mayor Bill DeBlasio according to the New
York Post his wife chirlane McCray and
their two kids spent a couple of days at
Bernie Sanders his summer home on Lake
Champlain
in Vermont that would be his third home
photos show the progressive politicians
and their families at Sanders his four
bedroom retreat in north hero Sanders
his unruly crop of gray hair covered by
a white cap is hitting shirtless in a
lawn next to his wife Jane uh.well
McCrae relaxes just steps away to their
right so this is this is all you know
it's all fabulous this is the beauty of
socialism here in the United States
socialism means they get to sit on the
banks of the river Champlain shirtless
wearing a white cap looking like a
refugee from weekend at Bernie's but
actually at a weekend at Bernie's and
you and you have your own lake house so
socialism is pretty awesome when you
never actually have to experience it so
that's that's pretty exciting stuff
there from from the socialist among the
final thing that I like so this is also
pretty spectacular
apparently there's a group of lesbians
who decided that they were going to lie
down install a transgender parade that
the London pride parade on Saturday so a
group of eight women stormed the parade
route according to the gay star news and
unfurled banners reading trans activism
erases lesbians and lesbian equals
female homosexual and apparently the
protesters stalled the parade for around
10 minutes and as they were carted off
one could be heard screaming a man who
says he's a lesbian is a rapist saying
if a man says that he's a woman that is
not true and a woman having sex with a
man even if he says he's a woman is
still having heterosexual sex with a man
which is biologically true one of the
great ironic elements of the LGBT
movement is that the T totally overrides
the L and the G that if you are that
transgender as it makes the argument
that gender is entirely a social
construct lesbianism
and homosexuality male homosexuality
make the argument that not only is
gender not a social construct a
preference for one gender above the
other is in fact biologically engrained
so if you prefer a male right then that
is because it is biologically ingrained
in you but transgenderism argues that
you can't biologically prefer male
because male mailed them itself is a
biological and sociological construct so
it doesn't really exist transgenderism
destroys the lesbian and gay movement he
loves me an activist all right then they
went ahead and apologized for all of
this right they said that this is this
is something that we're not you know
what we're sorry this happened but one
of these activists told the media we
don't want any kind of penis in our
bedroom I'm really sad I have to
reassert this again this seems
relatively self evidence if you're a
lesbian that this is something that you
don't want your bedroom but it is
hilarious to watch as the left twists
itself
to avoid the obvious implications of the
movements that it supports and are in
conflict with one another okay time for
a couple of things that I hate okay
thing that I hate number one so the
President of the United States is now
tweeting out about his about his
relationship with Kim jong-un it turns
out the Kim jong-un was lying no no you
say Kim jong-un would never lie Kim
jong-un was negotiated with by the
President of the United States he's an
honorable man Kim jong-un is a mass
murderer who shoots people with
anti-aircraft guns and poisons them with
weapons of mass destruction in public
places Kim jong-un is one of the worst
people on planet earth okay here is what
bloomberg reports as US Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo touched down in
Pyongyang at 10:54 a.m. on Friday he had
a few details of his schedule in the
North Korean capital even which hotel
and his staff would he and his staff
would stay in not much was clear from
lunch with with counterpart Kim Jung
trolls to start filling in the
nitty-gritty details from the Singapore
declaration signed between the leaders a
handshake with Kim jong-un at least
seems certain in the end
Pompeyo stayed in either of the hotels
where he thought he'd be the North
Koreans took him his staff and the six
journalists traveling with the
delegation to a gated guesthouse on the
outskirts of the capital just behind the
mausoleum where the bodies of regime
founder Kim il-sung and Kim jong-il lie
embalmed and on occasion display it was
the start of a confused visit of less
than 30 hours marked by a pair of lavish
banquets that the secretary and his
staff appeared to dread for their length
and the daunting number of course is
presented by unfailingly polite waiters
he'll we learn of his own schedule hours
ahead of time in the meeting with Kim
jong-un it never happened despite
strenuous efforts from his staff also it
turns out that they're saying now that
the United States lied about the
denuclearization argument that they were
not actually going to denuclearize in
the first place and the Trump lied about
it and this has led President Trump to
tweet out and I am not kidding this is a
thing that the president of the United
out in the United States sweded out
quote I have confidence that Kim jong-un
will honor the contract we signed and
even more importantly our handshake he's
an evil dictator
handshake deals with the evil dictators
are literally a plot point in an Austin
Powers movie you don't make handshake
deals with evil dictators trust but
verify it requires actual verification
not we made a handshake and nail or
besties that's not how this works this
is why I was very critical with the
president meeting with Kim Jong hoon
this is why I thought that it was a
mistake this is why I thought that he
was being played that's why
thought that all of the premature
celebration was premature celebration
there's a lot of pressure suggesting
that it's really the Chinese who are
pushing the North Koreans not to not to
make and make nice with the United
States based on tariff plans is what
Lindsey Graham is saying senator from
South Carolina
here's what he had to say I see China's
hands all over this we're in a fight
with China we buy five hundred billion
dollars worth of goods for the the
Chinese they buy a hundred billion from
us they cheat and President Trump wants
to change the economic relationship with
China
so if our president Trump would not let
China use North Korea to back me off on
the trade dispute there's no doubt in my
mind that it's the Chinese pulling the
North Koreans back okay well I think
that's probably untrue I think that
there are two things one the Chinese
could be pulling the North Koreans back
because they're angry at the United
States for its tariffs which is you know
again not a reason to pull back from the
tariffs if they're for actual national
security purposes and not just because
Trump wants a trade war and thinks about
trade deficits too much because trade
deficits are stupid um but it could also
be that the North Koreans never intended
on fulfilling any of these promises
which is why none of them were on the
paper we read the entire agreement word
for word when it came out there was
nothing of substance in it nothing all
of this was it seems to me a foolish
enterprise if the president actually
believed he's gonna make a handshake
deal with one of the worst dictators on
planet earth okay time for a Federalist
Papers we were all the way up to
Federalist number 36 we're making steady
progress through the Federalist Papers
Alexander Hamilton writes this one too
this is in a series of six or seven
papers in which Alexander Hamilton makes
the case for why federal taxation power
should be less limited than a lot of
people were arguing he argues that the
states shouldn't worry that the federal
government is going to basically take
all the tax revenue he says there won't
be double taxation I think this is the
weakest part of the Federalist Papers I
think that Alexander Hamilton radically
underestimated the desire of the federal
government's tax so he says many
specters have been raised out of this
power of internal taxation to excite the
apprehensions of the people double sets
of revenue officers duplication of their
burdens by double taxation and the
frightful forms of odious and oppressive
poll taxes have been played off with all
the ingenuity arity of political
legerdemain he says everybody's lying
when they worry about double taxation I
can guarantee you that Alexander
Hamilton was wrong about this we get
double taxed in California like nobody's
business and we have two separate sets
of people who are actually enforcing the
taxes in the in the United States we
have state tax off
and we have federal tax officers none of
it is good so I am with the
anti-federalists on this one Alexander
Hamilton's argument in favor of
broad-based taxing power for the federal
government was I think was short-sighted
I understand he was attempting to set
the United States on firmer fiscal
footing at the time he never could have
imagined the income tax for example no
one could have considering that that was
only legalized in nineteen nineteen
sixteen I believe what the sixteenth
amendment but in any case the arguments
that that Hamilton was making with
regard to the to the taxing power seems
a little bit short-sighted it seemed
like you know he was he was trying to
get something through his 1913 rather
the sixteenth amendment but his argument
in Federalist thirty-six is not his
strongest argument he says that state
tax officers will end up collecting
additional taxes for the federal
government and that the states won't be
adversarial to the feds because the feds
are picking up their debts that was the
one area where he was right the states
it turns out don't care that much all
about the federal the federal tax burden
because it'll just raise taxes
willy-nilly anyway as we have learned in
California okay we'll be back here
tomorrow at this time tomorrow we will
note the Supreme Court pick by the
President of the United States and we
will have all the information on it then
and I'm sure the fire fight will begin
so be there or be square
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing